for me the struggle was the amount of
people and the amount of talent and you
don't know where I think I felt like me
in high school where I'm like I don't
know where I belong who do I who gets me
here who understands me you're kind of
um trying to find yeah where you fit and
and I tend to
I think when I'm around like
big groups and you know people that are
have more power or confidence I tend to
get small and quiet because I don't I
don't like yelling I don't know how to
explain it but I don't want to have to
get bigger than the bear someone where
I'll just if I get too anxious I'll go
to my rooms
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola with me
dry cleaners
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
oh my God
you know Gail do you know Gill's
credentials
I just introduced myself to her uh
formerly Gordo
carrying the torch carrying the torch
for what are those everywhere
so this is the way this is the way that
police work
s okay
you have a lot of officers that are on
the job maybe they're not entirely
trained the right way you would agree
yes across the maybe across the world
even across I can say Across the Nation
and then you have security guards about
those with the iron on patch
flashlight that's all they got that's
what they can only hit you with the
light
and then you have detectives who have
credentials and are stars in crime in
the world of crime Frank solar no caught
the The Night Stalker
the Hillside Strangler because it's part
of Manson and those guys
you were the the first guy I always say
he was the first person that was
breaking it down to where he said it's
one person and everybody said it's got
to be two guys not one guy [ __ ] two
it's two guys are doing this he said
it's I'm telling you it's one guy
and it was one guy it was one guy and
then you get to the age of what how old
were you still you're pretty young yeah
I was oh [ __ ] I was 35 it was only about
40. it was only there I got there at 31
and it was five years after that so I
was only 36 years old when this happened
I wanted to ask you to retire
I actually retired when I was 60 years
old okay still young
and then you go home and that's and
there you are like you're you're
important
and then you retire and then you go home
and and the rest of your life you're
you're this person that's great at what
you did but then you're home there's
nothing so the the so the documentary
came out
and then he came in here and he was in
here and he was great
and we gave him pronounce the [ __ ]
dudes all over crime con and all that
[ __ ]
he loves to talk he wants to be a
[ __ ] Mariachi and a foreign
I'm very excited to have you here by the
way I really am because you know there's
a lot of questions uh that I would like
to ask you and and I think that they're
questions that in order to like I know a
lot of people that have had careers as
as stand-ups or Comedians and then have
gone through the the machine of
Saturday Night Live and then I remember
watching it when it first came on like
50 years ago maybe if it's if it's the
anniversary so we're so almost when they
get a new class if High School Musical
had his [ __ ] together
if we could be watching every every year
of our High School Musical but so you
were probably like the mass Exodus
almost of the cast I think almost like
seven or seven seven of you almost left
before we do that before
into the tidbit we have the incomparable
Melissa via Senor
if there was a comparable who would it
be
I don't know what Comfort what does that
mean incomparable is like Beyond
comparison wow that's very nice it's
it's extremely nice
and and
um and she's from all she's from your
neck of the woods that's right here too
I'm from Pico Rivera oh yeah yeah well
when I moved there was just Pico yeah
and then they had the Rivera then they
added the Rivera that didn't come till
about 58 59. oh interesting oh it was
just what did the Rivera come from
was that that lady that was talking [ __ ]
about um no oh no no the lady that was
there that councilwoman no no
but I'm happy I'm happy
it's now because her sister her sister
was on the city called for San Fernando
when is that the one Cindy yes that's
that is she was on the city council
we're gonna end up probably punching
this word up but they're like putitas
the Two Sisters
that's the one that
you know smack the other councilman
that's the one that's when I got fired
because I wouldn't sweep it under the
carpet
well they they said because they were
going in a different direction bottom
line that's what it was
no you
we'll get back to you I feel like it was
gonna be like Melissa and I sharing a
beer with our Theos
[Applause]
is
sing happy birthday I'm a [ __ ] throw
that cat [ __ ] cake in the street
take it easy
I drink beer every now and then
hey Adam the other day oh there we go
how was that that was good was it good
and he saw any Tajin or anything like
that ice
I didn't that well that was at the
Dodgers game so it was just in like have
you been drunk have you ever been like
shit-faced drunk
um a long time ago I think you keep it
together I'm getting this I do keep it
to get well now getting older I'm like I
can only have like two drinks and then
that's it I really am not a big drinker
and then I I could get
yeah when's the recovery time goes I
feel like just everything goes like you
just don't do it you know listen if you
can't recover
why then why because it's the pain of
the the pleasure of of being drunk and
laughing
does not compare to the person that's
true it's the controlling of it though I
think with age you get to know you know
one drink too much you know I can have a
good time
later
grapefruit and hibiscus
no I'm trying it matches your hair the
um
why were you born in you know I don't
know but it was in West Covina in West
Covina I don't remember the name of it
and then your parents
yeah
because you have to start somewhere it
was like a saint something Hospital
Covina
there it is and your parents are from
Mexico
my yes yes yes my mom's family is from
Tijuana and my dad is from my dad's my
grandpa's from Sonora and then my
grandma's from Aguascalientes
I got a whole Finding Your Roots you did
yeah like info now who was an
entertainment in your family no one who
sang in your family
just my tail Alfredo he wanted to be it
was like a Mariachi singer he seemed
really good because there has to be
somebody like I know but no one else
there's some did somebody want to and
then didn't because you know it it it's
it's I don't know it's such a it's such
a a departure from what you grew up
watching and grew up the people around
you I think yeah right like none of them
were like oh my dad's gonna go do this I
mean but he was a musician he played in
a band I wanted to play guitar I play
guitar every day but I wasn't I'm not
good at it my engine was born her mom
was an SMU great actress and very funny
and then you know whatever
it has to come from some place either
from neglect or it comes from to please
somebody you know would you you know the
whole this neglect is a powerful
a powerful motivator
yeah and your dad what did you what'd
your father do your mom work yeah
they're still working oh wow my dad's a
fence contractor he puts up Gates yeah
um and my mom does bookkeeping and she's
my book accountant
there we go
what did she told you okay she's like
stop buying that junk I buy a lot of
cochinello I like a little trinkets
[Laughter]
um yeah stop by like what do you like
what do you like though I mean are you a
side of the road type oh pull over I
mean I like I'm really attracted to like
colorful like toys and stuff like I
don't know
um what did I buy
I mean I just I'm remembering I bought
an inflatable Globe so I could learn
about the planet and have fun you know
punch it around with my friends
and my mom's like why are you buying
this funny is that she bought she bought
an inflatable Globe so she could learn
about the world and then punch it around
with her friends in the air
Ecuador
I mean that's I mean that's a it's nerdy
as [ __ ] but yeah it's awesome I'm
definitely a little weird and then when
you were growing up like what cartoons
were you watching like what where did
you get your entertainment man I mean we
would watch a lot of Animaniacs
um I'd like they were great animated
they never really got to really kind of
explore yeah they were like the regular
well there were like a bunch of
different characters right but they were
like the wild crazy versions of their
brother their cousins that were like the
Warner Brothers ones
they were smaller and crazier almost
like you had a family that showed up
you're like oh the [ __ ] my Knuckles
are here
God your cousin's little that's my dad
uh
um Animaniacs was great too right yeah
the way they talked and the things they
did and picking the brain oh that was
part of them right and the pigeons and
stuff
um
felt like we were always home though we
were always watching like TGIF those
Fridays you know Sabrina the Teenage
Witch
um I watched a lot of Jim Carrey movies
though growing up too I think that was
kind of my first taste of like oh I like
how Looney is yeah same here actually
yeah you showed me Ace Ventura and I got
hooked I should have told when she was
seven I had it that was way too early
yeah I think that was like me too yeah
did you see when Nature Calls first or
Pet Detective Pet Detective first okay
and then I think which I was the good
gradual
when did you realize that you could you
could do things you could do things like
see something and then do it
and I was because at school if you're if
you could do that in school I mean that
also you're such a great impressionist
an impressionist it takes not everyone
can do that yeah I was like listening to
so much pop music at that time in
seventh grade and I had an ear for I was
like hearing Brittany so much just like
oh baby baby you know I'm a slave for
you and then I would hear Christina
oh
and then I would listen to Shaquita and
but I wasn't but I was like listening to
them I was also home a lot you know I
couldn't go out a lot I wasn't I was
just like
I would just get wrapped up in these
singers then I started sharing them with
my friends at school and then I they
were laughing I was like oh I feel like
I I have something different yeah so you
you had the ear but were you are you
dyslexic
I don't know do you process do you read
or do you process more
by auditory like I I found out I think
sometimes you find out that
to read it you would never understand it
but a lot of us maybe if I would say to
somebody
um let me hear you say it and then I
would turn this way oh yeah like what
kind of learner are you and I would go
okay say it again okay oh well I mean I
had trouble in school yeah I couldn't
comprehend reading and so I I'm better
visual learning I think an audio
auditory visually is where you you do
the work in your head and someone who
doesn't would look on the page and do it
but you're not going to learn how to do
an impression by by looking at a video
or a page so you hear it and you can be
in another room and go oh what what is
that so yeah then it gets in your head
okay and then you start to think you
start to deduct in your head I can I
think I can yeah yeah and I had a little
like cassette recorder you know and I
was just hearing going back and forth
like oh I think that's it and where did
you get the cassette recorder did you go
buy it
and then somebody have it around the
house maybe someone had around the house
maybe she stole it you know I used to
have a consumer I think I think you have
to you have to because you want to hear
what it sounds like because yeah that
was before the phone imagine your day
when they used to interview a suspect
and nobody I did it and then nobody had
a [ __ ] recorder like well I didn't I
didn't say that you did when we did
interview you know you sit there and say
audio and visual there were during
interviews they're basically three kind
of people Audio Visual and kinesthetic
so you ask what's the first thing you
what's the first thing come to your mind
what do you when you think of your
grandmother and you would say if I said
what what first thing come to you when
you think of your grandmother the fake
fruit in their place here you go fake
food visual
then I know oh yeah I'm gonna hear my
questions she's a visual person if she
said I could hear my grandma saying
right now hey come on out get in here
she's an audio person and if she says oh
she was so loving I can just feel
hugging she's a kinesthetic you know she
feels it so you
and it doesn't feel like it would be a
question that you go I can't answer that
no say oh and then there you go then you
now you're being that's really cool
whoa
yes and what year are we talking about
now what year is this in your life you
are you an only child no no I'm middle I
have older brother and then you have a
younger brother and sister there and oh
wow there's a four four of us and did
they aspire to be with their employees
or athletic or anything
um they're all creatives like my
brother's like a creative designer for
Spotify and he worked out like he's just
a good Tech guy yeah uh Ali now my
sister's is studying acting in New York
she's going to school yeah and uh
Andrew's out here construction
engineering yeah
go Scott yeah it's pretty good yeah and
your parents are still married how long
they've been married now
38 years
wow that's incredible I think so
yeah they're probably yeah they're
probably yeah I'm a mom's so brutally
honest and tough my dads are just a
little softy he's Goofy and my mom will
be like Mike you don't know that you
don't know what you're talking about you
don't know he's like oh yeah he's like
hey loopy let me just try to sleep
like the other day the other night my
dad and I were looking at the moon you
know we're kind of the same little we're
a little aloof yeah you know we're like
ah why is it only half a moon is that
the Earth or the Sun blocking and my
mom's like you guys don't know anything
no and she was like explaining it but
Dad and I were just like okay
[Laughter]
so funny go across the street and look
at it
um the guy said one time that you know
when the cordless phones came out that
he said he told his mom hey mom if you
use the phone in their name in their
yard they get charged for the call
and he goes I come home from work and my
mom's in the in their yard in the
driveway oh yeah
she believed
they if you use your phone they would
charge that account
so yeah so I like that and then and then
what did you did you go what years what
year is this you're young
yeah
um in 2000s yeah so I when I graduated
from high school I started doing open
mics immediately wow well where the
where Dad did I was we did I went to the
ice house first and then like the uh the
annex room there was again yeah that
ranch was there and then uh someone from
there was like hey come do my bringer
show at The Comedy Store the bringer
shows I got caught up in you know the
beginning years
oh yeah so then so then I started doing
Open Mic so The Comedy Store and that
was the club that really brought me in
admits you passed me for the belly room
and and so I was that's where I was
getting the stage time to like they were
like you could work out here weekly and
get better and at that point how long
were you doing it you're probably not
right so you were pretty good pretty
fast I think there was that thing of
like me being a rare thing with the
Impressions and everything they didn't
have that no there wasn't around in the
comedy club so I think it was for them
it was like a special thing to have so
it's it was really nice but I wasn't
funny I was I was okay
yeah but you but you your impressions
though but you didn't know what we're
writing jokes I was I felt like the
beginning was just like here's this
celebrity voice here's this you know
kind of bits for the impression did you
put glasses on or did you just do them
no I just was them as as me but then
Through Time eventually I started making
fun of myself talking about my family
and and integrate like having both you
know right because it was good and did
Barbara Walters you did something with
your hair you put it oh that was an
early thing too that America's Got
Talent like I just met that was like 90
seconds
let's talk about America's Got Talent
now you you're probably watching the
show right and then and then somebody
said to you oh or you thought because
listen yeah you have to have [ __ ]
balls to go on America That's Got Talent
I mean I can't I could not do it either
that or no brain yeah you know like the
Chinese guy that went up there and did
the dance you know and he's still still
famous today and some of those people
I didn't want to do it someone I did the
show and this lady was like Hey I'm
helping set up auditions and you wanted
you should do it and I was like you got
scouted no no no
no no there was somebody there in the
audience watching yeah and I was like
I'll do it but I'm not gonna try hard
and then they're like great congrats
You're Gonna Fly to Seattle no
no
what did you do I did
um Barbara Walters Natalie Portman uh
Miley Miley Christina Aguilera Kathy
Griffin oh let's see can you they would
do that before you do something you were
good I mean this was my Natalie Portman
wow it's so amazing to be here I can't
believe this is crazy
this is amazing
uh
and uh I like that I mean Barbara
Walters I was just copying um sugar
Terry's Barbara Walters you know just
this is Barbara Walters you know
so Barbara Walt is talking dirtish
Olivia
[Laughter]
is it fascinating
um Miley Cyrus
hey this is Miley Cyrus
oh my God that's so I'm just saying
their names
is like you know that's true yeah
it's a little bit of a high or silver
face
my kids didn't know who the guest was
going to be today you know I I didn't
see him so I didn't tell him I did tell
my wife and my wife was excited that she
was gonna be down here today you're
you're a talented person everything that
Mayan said about you in the beginning
very true and and were you and you flew
up did anybody go with you no you know
because I know because I know what it's
like to go I like to dig into the when
you got there you gotta take a cab you
had to go to the thing your next day you
went like you got ready you know what I
mean it's yeah I think myself when I'm
under pressure like that I like being
alone because if someone's in my head oh
my God I would be like get away yeah get
away from me yeah if someone's if
someone said it
is this what you're doing oh my God oh
my God oh yeah let me have that down I
get really I get almost like violent me
too yes it's like get away from it's
like you know
and then and then you went up there and
then you you was it in a theater yeah it
was some big theater in Seattle
like the Paramount
maybe yeah
and then you went up the wow and then
you went well it was so funny because
Nick Cannon was like I'm seeing it and
he was like I didn't hear him but when I
walked on stage he tells the camera
let's hope she doesn't suck and oh thank
goodness I didn't hear that because I oh
thank God you didn't but uh he's [ __ ]
turbanon hey no no
but I ended up it ended up being really
great I was I I didn't know what to
expect because I was I knew that show
people could look really stupid and I
was like I don't know about this but it
ended up being well you had a lane
though I mean yeah that was what was
cool I was like oh there's no one else
here like that was doing what I was
doing any meat and the thing is you know
with Impressionists like when you do
yours immediately even when your face
changes you know who it is so there's
not like
oh I mean so you you get to it yeah but
also on your YouTube channel you did
such a great thing where you would have
the day planner of like Owen Wilson or
you do Kristin wig days
and you would do the whole day you would
do you make videos
like web series with most of my heart
Fred Fred Fred Armisen and Horatio
Sensei like made a channel for Latino
comics on Broadway video but a while
back before SNL I did like a few
episodes web series where I would have a
celebrity I play a celebrity at their
desk planning their plan their their day
on their planner so it's like Owen's
like yeah 8am sing with the bird outside
my window yeah he's a really nice bird
and I would plan out the schedule you
know and then I had Gwen Stefani and I
had Kristen wigs like I'm gonna have a
cup of tea you know so just like it
sounds like I had it it was a cute
little like didn't you do one with JLo
oh yeah
I did a JLo one she's like I'm on a I
don't know I'm gonna dance
I don't remember though I have to like
continued myself because I could
probably quote just things he said I
said now like for sure like
[ __ ] nerds unite I am such a I'm a
nerd
that's not offensive to nerds is it no I
love it
freak flag fly
because you know it's like before
but I think you know people are afraid
of what they don't know it's it's funny
though all the people that were that
were little mencitos they all got their
[ __ ] together yeah all the guys that
walked into class with a girl on their
arm you know a lot of those you know out
there look at the garbage barefooted
uh so there is a a way of uh the way
people aged it's almost like uh when
they go this one's here and then like
those horse races that you play when you
shoot water in them and the horse moves
and then you think that was going to win
and then the other ones that since I
could the the the time it takes someone
to grow into
[Music]
because they're inside they're smart
then they grow into their confidence and
then they find their thing and then yeah
it's just easy to them yeah when you did
that AGT the first one
Howie Mandel was beside himself I mean
you had him from the very beginning when
you came out with Barbara Wawa you know
she he was in you know comedian said oh
she's got it and did anybody go over
with you and to say or you put you put
it together the way you wanted it to
right like you said this is what I'm
trying to get in my head of like what to
do and then I kind of silenced and I was
like I'm just gonna do what I think is
best because in the end that's I'm the
only one right you know so ended up
being okay
and how did you feel during all that
once you get that first laugh then
you're kind of like all right I got I'm
gonna happen
but I was nervous leading up to it for
sure
it takes balls I mean it really does
take balls you know that I know when
you're out there and you just the whole
[ __ ] United States the [ __ ] world
is watching like I know but that was a
thing that's a big show it's a huge show
when did you start to see like when you
went out people started to recognize you
yeah I felt like I mean after that
appearance I was able to go on the road
you know that was which was bittersweet
because I only had a couple years of
stand up in me so I was bombing oh
really I'm crying all over the U.S oh
[ __ ]
oh here's the girl that she was on AGT
yeah that was 90 seconds but then you I
have to do a half hour then an hour oh
yeah
so for Impressions so my future Act was
killing and then I would go up and just
bomb it was hard but it's it's you know
what it made me tough I guess it does
make you tough
but man those those nights because I
don't want to be near me because I don't
want to be near me because Impressions
like you could it's not like you could
do
two songs of an impression of and right
unless you take a spin on it or you have
to make it your um
that's what force me which was great
that's what forced me to start writing
about myself because I was like I don't
want to be doing an hour of only about
celebrities like ew yeah no it would
make me sad inside I'm like no I'm
Melissa I got I got a lot of things to
talk about yeah that's right yeah
so yeah so that was like after for a few
years after America's Got Talent going
on the road did you did you admire what
what female what comedians did you
admire
growing up I mean when I started
watching stand-ups I felt like Wanda
Sykes was one of my favorites uh
Walter Sykes because you know one of the
great impression Wanda Sykes too oh my
God that's right how did I do my one
it's been like where is Wanda let me
find it let me find her
I also want to be here
I mean it's that's also because
yeah yeah the [ __ ] eyes
he doesn't have a kill carrier
[Laughter]
after a third life you'll be guilt shut
up
one time one time on New Year's Eve the
first comedian goes up I've been working
in Addison at The Improv and you're here
hey man I could go on the office I said
did you hand out those [ __ ] party
favors
people aren't going to use them until
midnight
every time every time the dude told a
joke
[Music]
I said listen
if you blow that [ __ ] horn again
I'm gonna jump off the stage I'm gonna
take that [ __ ] horn yeah and I'm
gonna shove it up your [ __ ] ass and
it's all quiet and the dude in the front
goes
yeah I thought for some reason it was
good everybody's all quiet all skated
one guy okay
frankly that's a great button man it's a
sad part
then I don't work on Halloween's because
I had a [ __ ] vampire heckling me oh
but you know isn't it out there it's
like when no one's watching and there's
no cameras nobody gives a [ __ ] all you
have to do is not be late because the
only the only time they care about you
is when you're late
so when you do a show you have 23 hours
to your all to yourself and the only
thing that they care about is the next
day don't be late
and now you have the whole day to figure
out what to do in Utah or wherever but
you know when you when you decide to
write like your moment was you're like
[ __ ] I gotta figure out how to fill this
time and then you're out there and it
forces you to to dig and to find things
to talk about yeah
yeah
and it's not easy
like would you say like when you get
scouted for the SNL process like when
after AGT like one like how far from
that did you get scouted for SNL or do
you think when they try to find you for
SNL how important do you think it is of
oh this is someone that can Encompass
everything that we need for the show or
how much do you think individuality runs
into it or do you need to be kind of be
a chameleon and kind of be or is it a
little bit of trying questions
of like when you get because you're an
impressionism but you're such a unique
individual is like with the uh with the
casting process of it or are you being
found to be in a be auditioning
like do they do you think they what
helped you was your individuality and
you being I knew so because I auditioned
man I don't know it was before the year
before AGT or something yeah I was like
21 when I first auditioned and I did
okay because I had good Impressions but
I wasn't a person yet right you know I
didn't know who I was so I didn't get it
and then you know years went by more
life and more what did you audition at
um I went I flew out there I submitted
yeah I went to the stage they saw the
tape and all that yeah
um and then I re-auditioned well they
they actually Al Madrigal he had me in a
showcase and one of the producers
romance no was there this was 2016. and
uh I just feel like my stand-up set
2016. yeah and then I got the the show
then but it flew out again and when they
they called you your agent called you
yeah yeah they were like they want you
to fly out in audition again wow I was
like wow seven years later
pretty cool it's incredible
but there and then you went in addition
again and then
they said then I had more meetings with
the writers and and Lauren and then then
I flew back home and they're like you
got this but you but you didn't think of
it like they don't have any you're the
first Latino person I didn't even think
yeah no no truly I was just like this
was my kid dream you know that's the
[ __ ] that I I thought about because I
mean look at me
the first indigenous person but I mean
you know when you look at you have to I
feel yeah I mean you just you just did
it wasn't a time to change too times you
know you didn't you were an
impressionist you had your abilities and
yeah
and I felt more
you know more of who whatever like more
myself and and everything that you had
gone everything that you had done even
in the clubs and all that stuff prepared
you for that right I mean yeah that's
what happened that's what I realized
when I was auditioning and everything I
was like thank God for those hard shows
thank goodness for all those all those
shows that I thought didn't even matter
they all added up and really mattered
yeah you should make the mistakes yeah
yeah I think that's a good one I think
that people when they if they eat it you
know they get depressed but it's a
lesson it's not a negative it's a
positive because everybody's gonna eat
it but if you do and then you decide to
fight back and not be the person that's
just eating it like you know this guy's
gonna eat it you know and then you start
to just to create a space for yourself
what you did and you had a lane I mean
it was it's incredible I mean look at I
mean over here this is my high over rate
incredible field of work yeah and then
and then you had to move out there wow
that's I know and I'm from here so that
was a that was another thing another
layer that City what did you yeah what
did you what did you start to see like
what did you see what did you where did
you you run an apartment in the yeah in
the city no the show helped you yeah
well I mean my sister was already out
there which was a great blessing yeah I
wouldn't have hacked it but she helped
me like find it was like a broker I
guess to look for a place
um and the studio apartment faced the
one window I had facing a wall
and I was in the darkness whenever I was
home so it was like that what a city how
did they do it
uh-uh because you're from because
Sunshine baby we're from here and none
of our Windows face a [ __ ] wall ever
really I mean yeah and Sun not weather
not cold and not impersonal where I
remember when I went I said hey man you
know what time it is [ __ ] it's like what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] like
uh I'm not sure if you're aware but we
don't talk to each other here like just
everybody walking down the street nobody
talking
yeah to each other they're just
everybody's got a place to go but then I
that so that was the first season but
then the the following year I moved out
to Brooklyn which was oh great lower
buildings and my sister was there so I
lived right around the corner from her
um because she was a great cook you know
I go over and eat yeah yeah sure of
course yeah my her and my brother-in-law
just just refuel just refueling yeah
yeah yeah so that was what was fun and
uh yeah by that time by that time when
in the city we started to go out and
people started to come up to you and I
feel like a few years after yeah no no
no
yeah
I think after I had some good things
that to share on the show right some
things I like
and then the week is the weakest hardest
day as they say it is it is it's almost
it's almost inhumane right yeah it's a
roller coaster yeah the whole week is
they get together and then they start to
figure out what ideas yeah
your heart's just broken but I mean it's
also but it's magical too when you get
something you really put your heart in
and it gets to air you're like it's it's
a magical feeling yeah so it's it's good
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure is is it
like
um
trying to uh please a parent that's a
parent that's like a
that's tough on you and you bring
something oh this is great
let's try again yeah yeah no I feel like
it for me the struggle was the amount of
people and the amount of talent and you
don't know where I think I felt like me
in high school where I'm like I don't
know where I belong who do I who gets me
here understands me you're kind of um
trying to find yeah where you fit and
and I tend to
I think when I'm around like
big groups and you know people that are
have more power or confidence I tend to
get small and quiet because I don't I
don't like yelling I don't know how to
explain it but you don't want to have to
get bigger than the bear someone where
I'll just if I get too anxious I'll go
to my room so I would do that sometimes
in my office and I didn't know how to
dive in with the amount of people sure I
don't know how to explain it
introvert that's what it is but also I
mean is that the amount of
I mean the amount of I mean imagine
being in a room full of generals yeah
exactly the noise so why may you know
wait for my time be strategic if
everybody's important who's more
important I understand and you just I
mean I think anybody would would go that
way I mean yeah but then I've found good
pals you know that that wrote from like
wrote with me uh my friend Stephen
Castillo helped me write a few fun
sketches and like uh we made one of my
stand-up bits of sketches called dying
Miss Gomez it's just me as an old lady
one of my Santa fits where I just sing
Nickelback as a final words in my desk
and uh and so that was a really fun
sketch to do and I was like well that
came for me but it's [ __ ] obscure
like yeah that's weird way [ __ ]
obscure and not anything that anyone
would expect so yeah yeah I think the
obscurity moves you closer to the front
of the line right as a wise man
yeah and so then through time I mean
certain writers I was like Oh They'll
they're good at writing something like
this and they want to get it they're
good at some that person's great at
writing something that's a celebrity
impression you know so then it's then
you figure out you started yeah who has
who has it's almost like a boxer with
Corner people like you got the guy that
has the thing at the guy that has the
thing like on all together they find you
things that yeah you would like okay
I'll do that because it's really them
telling the boxer everybody to do this
you know they're watching do this right
and everybody has their own specific uh
uh conductor of an orchestra yes give me
this give me this and here's the
finished product that's it what were you
where were you when what got on First
and where were you when you did you
watch it
the first year well yeah that
um it would go on YouTube like Clips
yeah and stuff but after but uh
the first year was super hard but thank
goodness Mikey day and Streeter
um the streeter's a writer and Mikey's
on the cast but he writes so many
brilliant pieces they wrote that dirty
talk sketch for me and uh Aziz so I'm
bad at dirty talking and uh yeah
that was like the first thing that was
yeah it's a sketch where I'm
bad I keep yeah it was like a talk he's
like talk dirty to me I'm like yeah
and it's just like me
um yeah he's like role play I'm like
yeah pretend you're yeah hey girl I'm
like yeah I'm a little girl I'm six
I don't know I'm bad at school I was
like oh yeah it's like I'm tutoring it's
like I have a math disability I'm like
yeah I have a learning disability and
you're like no no like a sexier problem
a sexier problem to have you're just
like damn good it's crazy because it
goes well how about this and he keeps
doing it oh my God see it was the best
because they were like oh let's do role
playing and it was like oh okay it was
like and then Aziz was Australian he was
like oh you want to play with my
didgeridoo
is a funny man himself oh my God it's so
good
yeah so that was like that that was the
first season but yet
I did grow each year though and yeah
yeah yeah and pretty cool and when
you're not there is it in your head the
whole time is it in your like thinking
of things if you went out and and things
is it like that like in my body still
like to thinking of like like I play in
a lot of those golf tournaments with the
pros and you know we want Pros but
the pros would just it just be about
their heads would just be about that the
whole time and I thought it's not you
know it's hard to disconnect yeah I
don't
nowadays now it's now the show I'm not
thinking of sketches anymore yeah it was
like but I think yeah it's a big yeah
it's a big it's a big thing I felt like
it was
yeah I just yeah how are you feeling
even just after that's such a huge part
of your life I know it's almost still
strange right now too like my body's
like used to that schedule and Rhythm
and and I don't know it is I've still
gone through a little now you're back
out here back on the west coast yeah get
to rest I need a recall regress and hang
out uh
do you go perform do you go oh yeah yeah
I go to the comedy story improv and any
other Laugh Factory
um
but it feels good I think now my brain
is just thinking of
silly thoughts any ideas for stand up
and
that's where I'm at right now when I
draw
I do art yeah and what do you and what
do you want to do
what do you think you want to do
don't say direct no probably acting but
also singing of my own kind of variety
show like a Pee-Wee Herman type thing
yeah I don't know why I'm like that'd be
fun if it's in your head yeah yeah oh
you definitely could you could do a good
Pee-wee Herman impression with that
voice I know you could no I I was just
like thinking I don't know I really
don't know yet I think I kind of want to
live and travel and stuff so I could see
what I want to do next I feel like there
is a little bit of pressure on me like
oh while people are still thinking of
you get a show I'm like but I don't but
you know what I was like I was talking
about Lopez versus Lopez I was telling
Maya that I said I wonder I wonder what
she wants to uh
that'd be cool
yeah I think I'm just I just wanna
write and live and
see what I don't want to force stuff too
yeah you're not you know in the club
you're not you don't feel like you have
to go to the clubs or well no no comedy
clubs I always do I love being
in terms of like creating a show
I don't I don't know yeah what that is
yet you've earned the time to wait more
than yeah yeah it's like let me breathe
when you
step away because
I mean it's very anti-latino to leave a
gig when you don't get fired or they
catch you okay stealing that's what was
real hard for me I mean serious really
my mom was like I mean really don't
don't people stay if they get a gig like
people I grew up around if they're if
they worked they worked until the
factory left or they they never left a
good like what could be considered and
your mom said that to you yeah she had a
tough time kind of
she didn't understand but but I know she
she was like I know it's hard but it's a
steady you know but I get it for example
yeah but I also think of like my parents
when the four of us when we were kids
I'm sure it was like that was yeah you
don't let go of something but
in this case I was also worried about
just my mental health a bit I had some
panic attacks at work last season and I
was like I don't I'm having too much
this is too hard for me oh [ __ ] just
the pressure and I was like I don't
think I want to keep and keep myself
matters in that place you know the one
the one thing that uh I think hasn't
changed about Saturday Night Live is if
you look at you know
baseball or any sport where there's a
high is the amount of pressure that a
performer goes through oh I think the
thing that has not changed this they
still they still have the same structure
that started from Belushi and and
the the intensity of that week and as
you get things get cut people get you
know things get trimmed you're not in
this this and that and it's it's there's
no sure footing
on that show so you go through the
season you go to another season you go
through and all of a sudden it's just
it's so much yeah it's a lot and every
week I felt like I was I have to explain
like I felt like I was on the edge of a
cliff hanging on yeah like for like I
don't know you people on the inside see
it the viewer who doesn't know anything
about the business you know we don't we
don't see that we just see what comes
out we don't see the the work the labor
the stress the intensity of it all and
you'd never had a a panic attack before
not until then no there was one like one
table it was like a I know I was like
that's crazy I mean I've had stress
there where I've had back spasms that's
where it attacks manifested itself
wow fascinating and I'm walking around
the studio like this for the one I had
to get on air I had to hold it really
there was a few times that happened but
uh
and your back spasms just because of all
the amount of I mean I used to hear that
like silver here would have like intense
panic attacks like before he went on and
then like he would just turn go on and
to be like okay sometimes like there was
a sketch this past season where I kept
messing up my lines I hadn't been in an
episode for a few weeks so I got nervous
out there yeah and I got frightened and
and I messed up the line and I messed up
another line and there was a sketch I
had to exit with a dog and I start
crying on the side because I'm like I
can't I can't do this anymore and then I
had to go back out in the scene so my
face was like watery and I was just like
[ __ ] that was just like I was so mad at
myself and I was like I can't it's okay
it's just but you know
was it uh it was more than you're just
also sensitive and I yeah I think I'm
not a as tough of a fighter too as I I
don't know a moment is brave it's great
being brave too yeah but when you don't
listen I mean there's not many there's
not many jobs in this business where
you can't go to someone and say what's
it like
you know we're going on the road or
going like I went from going to clubs to
like a theater then you go to a theater
and then you go to a bigger theater and
then you go to an arena then you decide
to do it in the round because you could
sell more tickets and then you start
doing them in the round and they're like
how do you stand out there for 18 000
people in the round but it's not like it
doesn't go from like zero to 18 000
people it goes from like twenty five
hundred five thousand seven and it's not
it's not it's not a thing that
you open the door and you go what the
[ __ ] it it goes gradual so there's a way
there's an adjustment part of it but in
in Saturday Night Live there's it's
almost like he was in Vietnam
there's no way that unless you've been
to war that you're going to be able to
describe to somebody and they're going
to have them understand what it's like
to to or be under those conditions and I
think all of that is such a shock to a
person but you can't say to somebody
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] scare the [ __ ] out
of YouTube yeah it'd be like no even if
they even if it was yes they would say
no because you can't there's other you
can confide in that way
because because nobody wants to hear
that oh yeah yeah for sure it's it's
yeah and then you go home when you yeah
yeah yeah
it really is sad to me
it really is sad that one has to go
through
such almost torture you know yeah to
yourself
it's okay you know yeah
I think yeah no it's okay I mean I've
there's there's in the end every
everything every year every season I
looked at my growth on that show
everything unraveled at the right time
like everything that aired that I wanted
to like it it found the right time I was
strong in those moments when it aired
you know so I think it's it all works
out yeah no yeah you know the price you
pay for
celebrity for faint for showcase your
work it takes a stove
did the Latino organizations come after
you no because no I think yeah I guess
if you're a performer you know because
you know a lot of times they'll say oh
the first Latina
um person on Saturday Night Live but
oh I don't no I don't think anyone
uh
uh no I mean sometimes sometimes groups
will say oh you know we'll give you this
award or whoa in a positive way no no
words
you're like no I mean like you probably
I mean sure you you have Awards right uh
the national Hispanic media Coalition
like our show hasn't even aired yet you
know it's just being that's great when
they give you I mean my I mean my end
mine you know
has been watching Saturday Night Live
Forever I mean forever forever and like
your presence on the show meant I'm not
trying like so much to me because I was
you know I went to Second City camp and
I studied come and I went to college
studying comedy writing and you came the
first year of my first year of college
studying comedy and I you know I didn't
see myself until I saw you and on the
same track that I wanted to go on and it
just gave me such a fire to be like I'm
gonna just hit it on because because she
did it now wow I can do it too and yeah
I went to the conservatory and
everything so mine got into Second City
and people say wow she was George Lopez
daughter I didn't yeah I actually love
college because there's a lot of people
where there's no [ __ ] pool I got no
pool it's like I mean there's no listen
you know that this is this isn't a
business where you go hey my daughter
wants to be in Second City yeah bring
her over and tell her that's for Jeremy
oh okay
so she got in on her own I wouldn't like
I didn't have the balls to do that you
know I think hopefully Arsenio doesn't
mind me saying this so Arsenio Hall
auditioned that second hit City and got
in but
he wasn't a sketch type of person still
was but but he did his thing he got in
and at that same time I think he got
offered an opportunity to go open for
maybe Gladys Knight on the road and he
said do I do stand-up which I'm more
comfortable in but also on a on a Farouk
I got accepted in the Second City
and he took he he because he knew that
second city was going to be tough he's
like [ __ ] that I know that's going to be
tough so I'm going to take doing
stand-up and he opened for like Gladys
Knight and Luther Vandross and and
people on the road
but I said you regret it he goes no not
really because
that I auditioned but I knew that that
was going to be difficult because of the
amount of characters and the things in
in the audience I wasn't expecting stand
up you had to give them you know
characters that do improv and stuff like
that so yeah mine yeah I went into
sketch because I was afraid of stand up
and then I was like oh if I wanted I
need but you need to you know do
stand-up because it helps you know
create your persona and create your
person and to go on there and now well
you know I'm on NBC now so yeah well I
told Maya not to do stand up because I
felt like I was good at it but I did in
Chicago I was afraid to do it here it's
almost like if if I if I again compared
to him it was just a lot of pressure if
somebody found out that I'd posed nude
when I was young
you don't want your kid to be you're
like listen I didn't pose nude so that
you could be out there and have yeah you
told me not to you're like you're like
look I know what it's like to be in
those classes so that my kid would have
to work in the clubs I would hope
so she made but she made her own
decisions to him
[ __ ] your dad
watch Saturday Night Live YouTube watch
you do this religiously and then Tick
Tock comes out and then Debbie Wolfe who
created you know Lopez versus Lopez saw
Mayan
like retort to um yeah someone made a
tick tock of
um my dad waking up from surgery and
being like Oh George Lopez has got a
kidney and then he cheats on his wife
and you know takes the you know and
divorces her and then I dwetted it and I
was like well that's not true and I was
like you know what what will get
people's attention I'm like you know
what I'm in a quarantine who's gonna
watch it I'm gonna torque upside down on
a wall because I think it's something
catchy and I'll catch people's attention
and you know I'm whatever and so I did
it with I was like no she divorced him
we get she gets money in alimony you
know
and it's all true by the way all true it
was like um no fake news here and um no
and then I saw I posted it not you know
meaning anything my mom actually didn't
want me to post it what are you doing
fool
you know some people are listening to
this too so I don't even know I'm just
as lost no no no you're right so so
she saw that and then
um and that's how the show got started
like Debbie Wolfe show runner saw that
Tick Tock that I made and then she saw
the other tick tocks and realized that
he saw the family and she was like oh my
God this is a show
and then she and she was an executive
producer co-executive producer on the
Connors and Bruce Halford was a
co-creator on George Lopez so it was
like a really weird Kismet thing and
then we all got in a meeting together
like we would have never thought to work
together now and it's Christmas yeah
that's a big word
hey he went to the that's the problem he
could go to private school you know so
and mine has been funny forever I mean
you know you know kids that are just
different they're just funny yeah it's
good to be funny it is
it's gonna be funny I would not trade
the ability to I mean in fifth grade
we would do the Pledge of Allegiance and
then one day I said
they said okay class did you was there
everybody stand up
put and she would say put your right
hand over your heart and before she said
it I said put your right ball over your
heart
and the whole class started laughing and
she's like what what did you say I
didn't say anything what did you say to
the teacher you said put your right ball
over your heart get the [ __ ] out of here
I went to the principal's office I'm
sitting in principal comes in I remember
he had like no type of thing he goes I
under I understand uh you think you're
funny I said I I don't know what did you
say what did you say I didn't say
anything what did you say I said
put your right ball under over your
heart
and the principal Court that's it you're
in it for that I said yeah it's funny I
had a similar story I I when I remember
I got
um I I would used to say everything he
said I had to create a filter in my head
because I used to just like the first
thing that's almost like a witch when
and I wouldn't even know what I was
saying and then people would laugh it
was just something in school and I
remember one time I said something I
don't even remember and I got in trouble
and I went to the no the kids stole the
soccer ball you said stop being a [ __ ]
and give us the ball back yeah a long
other thing I was also just funny you
know I was like and
um and uh that's comedic sure and um and
um and so I got sent to the headmaster's
office and my mom picked me up but from
school and so she was like so mine how
did the how was school today I was like
fine and she was like well um I heard
that you called uh so and so as like a
son of a [ __ ] I was like Mom I can't
help it just comes into my head and I
just think it's funny and she's like
well mine yeah to own what comes out of
your mouth like it was mean I'm like
mean but funny
um
and from there I always go back to that
story try to tell her like you know and
bewitched they have Tabitha the baby one
day they see the baby go like this and
the bottle flies across the room and
then Bewitched says I gotta have a talk
with her because she has the power that
that I have you know they're witches so
remember she did an episode where she
says you have to be very careful about
what you do with this and I had to tell
Mayan that things are going to come into
your head but be careful what you say
because they could be funny but also
they could hurt people too
I heard a lot of people yeah you know
but I'd be like don't you do it comedies
it stings it hurts sometimes and I think
you know now with
the way that people I mean I told a joke
that got the [ __ ] secret service
account of my house
and you're like what the I mean I really
are we really in this [ __ ] world yep
and they had everything that I'd ever
retweeted you know
on on Twitter question also Melissa
because I've asked him is like you know
do you write material with the fear of
getting canceled or do you think of is
that does that or does that affect your
material anymore or no I mean for me my
my bits are kind of childlike anyway so
I don't think I think that way and I
could feel it too if like even if I'm
trying to talk about dirty things on
stage I can't get too far I start
getting uncomfortable and the crowd
could feel it and like oh she can't do
this
but every time it's like oh that's it
feels mean or I hurt afterwards I'm like
that's not gonna work has Anna Navarro
Navarro seen you do her impression oh
yeah she loves it she's cool she's like
you come imitate me anytime I really
that's how I heard her too her message
me you know yeah I love it I love it I
think it's so funny it feels so good
that's cool that she loves it that's
your friend from Florida yeah she was in
here she was in here with us yes
oh man it went fast it went fast
um yeah okay
um well it's an art I mean the plug
Melissa my book comes out at the end of
the month it's called whoops I'm awesome
and it's so with my artwork and it's
funny and it's a little self-helpy but
it's awesome okay what is your what is
your artwork about
it's um I would compare it to like Shel
Silverstein artwork where it's simple
but meaningful you know child-like uh
I'll get you guys a copy amazing yeah
but yeah that comes out October 25th and
I'm I'll be doing like a little book
tour stand up tour
how's your podcast
thing with myself so it's only me oh
[ __ ] it then
you can be excited George I hope it got
turned down okay oh I thought you know
what I guess I know but I know I thought
you got me no I didn't get mad
all right
next one I do I'll be laughing about
myself
it's only like 14 15 minutes all right
thank you for coming in coming in I mean
I appreciate it I'll see you again I
hope I hope that we can see you uh hell
yeah because
we almost feel like you know we're
family were yeah thanks for having
Pioneers here okay
thank you